if you're gonna go like a paid marketing
route where you pay for advertisements
to promote your app do shots as they
were intended by blasting them directly
into your mouth awesome I'm wasted
that's gonna take a lot of money if
you're gonna go with the organic route
[Applause]
six things that I wish I knew before
building ASAP and failing miserably what
is up everyone and if you're watching
this video you probably fall into one of
two camps number one you're an
entrepreneur and you see the potential
of SAS apps that you want that sweet
sweet sweet recurring revenue or number
two you're well developer and you want
to monetize your skill and again you
want that sweet recurring revenue and I
was pretty much a mix of those two camps
I was a well developer and I got super
hyped on entrepreneurship and I thought
that SAS apps were gonna be my ticket to
make billions well that didn't happened
and after months of coding months of
Faerie on bugs months of making it look
pretty I was left with a whopping zero
paying customers so in today's video I'm
gonna go over everything that I wish I
would have known beforehand so that you
could potentially save yourself months
of work and you're gonna find out if
this is the right business for you to go
after because I do love this business
model of like recurring revenue every
single month but I also know that it's
definitely not for everyone so if you
want to learn about my mistakes about my
failures make sure you stick around to
the very end of the video and a lot of
people all social media they always brag
about the success but very few and
in-between ever talk about and explain
why
like they failed at what they failed
that so if you appreciate this
transparency smash that like button and
the subscribe button while you're at it
it's free and for that YouTube a gorilla
so let's give you guys some background
what is this a SAP why are there so
popular and what was my SAS app so what
is a SAS app well SAS stands for
software as a service and it's one of
those apps where you pay a monthly fee
usually monthly fee it can't be like a
yearly fee to use that service make
Netflix G suite by Google Amazon Prime
audible and a bunch of other small ones
and does I have to come from a very big
company and I believe there are four
main reasons why SAS apps are so popular
right now number one
probably the biggest point is that you
get recurring predictable revenue every
single month you know that a like the
majority of your users are gonna be
paying that next monthly fee there were
two reasons why SAS ops are so popular
is because they're super scalable
compared to other businesses for example
if you want to support more users all
you would have to do is like upgrade the
servers you're using and if you're using
like a server service something like
there's no ocean it's really just like a
clicking flip button and the fact that
it's really scalable also makes SAS
businesses have very low overhead for
example you don't have to rent out like
an entire office building if you don't
want to and number four and today's day
and age it's easier than ever to make
one they have a lot of pre-built code
for example to implement like a user
system or to use striped payments or set
up recurring payments but don't get me
wrong it's still really hard but it's
easier than ever so what was my SAS up
mine was called beautiful stuff and like
a lot of SAS apps it started out as just
me wanting to scratch my own itch and
back then I was doing a lot of swing
trading with stocks and if you don't
know what that is it's basically buying
and selling stocks within a few days to
a few weeks and to do that I would look
at graphs like stock charts and figure
out what the right time to buy on the
right time to sell was and I want to
automate that process of like analyzing
stock charts every single day because it
was getting like pain in the ass so I
made this app to automate that and for
users to make like custom alerts for
themselves alright let's get into those
six things that I wish I would have
known before I got started and before we
get into that I just want to reiterate
that this is not meant to discourage you
just because I feel that this does not
mean that you will feel that you will
get up this is just my experience that
I'm sharing with you guys again
I still love this business model number
one I wish I would have validated my
business idea first before I started
building the app this is literally all
that matters and is the difference
between you wasting your time and you
finding a really good idea that you can
go after and if you don't know what I'm
talking about the number one but I would
recommend for anyone looking to start a
SAS business is the lead startup that
would be linked below of course it's an
affiliate link for that passive income
but in a nutshell before you get into
mud
and months of development of life area
bugs of making it look nice you want to
validate that people would actually want
to buy like take off their credit card
fill out the form online to buy your
service or your app or whatever you're
trying to provide and you use what's
called an MVP to-do list and basically
it's just a super minimal super
bare-bones simple version of la app
you're trying to make to see and people
would be interested in that idea in the
first place and if the idea is not
validated you know that if you build us
app out people aren't going to buy
anyway so that you can just skip all
that trouble and move on to the next
idea especially if you're coming from a
what developer perspective like I was we
think our ideas are like super good and
everyone's gonna love it but really the
only opinion that matters is the opinion
of the marketplace or people in the
market actually gonna sign up for your
app and if they're not there's no point
in you making it unless it's just for a
hobby and of course I didn't do this
so I wasted a lot of time a number two
thing that I wish I woulda known before
starting is I wish I would've smash that
subscribe button to this channel alright
but all seriousness number two is I wish
I would've came at this from more of the
business side especially since I started
out as a developer and if you're in my
shoes you have to realize that the
business side of things and the coding
side of things are two completely
different things and just because you
can code does not mean you can do the
business part well you could make the
best effort it can have no bugs it can
look super nice and functions exactly
how you want it but if you don't know
marketing if you don't know sales and if
you don't know copywriting amongst other
things gonna have a bad time we have a
good guy so I recommend if you're in
that boat you're a developer I would
start learning the stuff as fast as
possible or you can also partner up with
someone that's really proficient on the
business side of things tonight you guys
can work together they can handle the
business side you can handle the coding
side or vice versa if you're coming at
this from the business side and you
don't want to outsource it to a giant
company that's gonna charge you like
thirty thousand dollars to fill out this
app you can partner up with a developer
you can handle the business side they
can handle the coding side but number
three thing I owe to the number three
thing I wish I were unknown is that
is a very steep learning curve on both
the business side and the tech side of
things again on the business side you
have to know marketing sales copywriting
and if you're going at this alone or
just with like one other person you're
gonna have to know and be good at like a
good number of different skills on the
tech side you have the front end of the
app and the back end of the app and if
you came at it from me where I was kind
of a beginner on both ends especially on
the back end it's kind of overwhelming
to learn both and make both sides of
things at the same time
number four Oh number four there is a
lot of competition with sass apps
because they are again the hot thing
that's going on right now
the main popular business opportunities
right now or like dropshipping Facebook
ad agencies ecommerce Amazon FBA I think
in the near future sass apps are gonna
be one of those next really big and
popular business opportunities and at
the end of this video I'm gonna share
with you guys a community that you can
go to to talk with a bunch of other sass
owners a bunch of successful ones and
beginner ones as well another thing you
have to keep in mind what competition is
that a lot of successful entrepreneurs
that are you know making a lot of money
within their service or personal brand
businesses are starting to move into SAS
apps as like the next business venture
because they have the capital to support
it and again all those great things I
mentioned about SAS apps they're really
scalable low overhead they like those
things too and they have a lot of
capital to support that so just know
that that's someone like those are like
some of the people that you're gonna be
competing with and based off of Elon
buses quote if you're a new company I
mean this looks like some new industry
or new market that if it's an untapped
market or then the standard is lower for
your product or service but if you're
entering anything where there's an
existing market place against lodge and
trenched competitors then your product
or service needs to be much better than
theirs it can't be a little bit better
because then you put yourself in the
shoes of the consumer and they say why
would you buy it as a consumer you're
always gonna buy the trusted brand
unless there's a big difference if
you're going into a niche like SAS apps
where there's a lot of competition just
know now you're gonna have to
put in a lot of work and make it a lot
better than competitors if you want to
stand out number five it's gonna take a
lot of work in fact it's gonna take 10x
more work 10x more money that you
initially expect on the tech side of
things there's gonna be a ton a ton of
bugs I did not imagine how many bugs
that I would have to work out and by the
end of it I still had like a ton of bugs
that I was just too lazy to fix and yeah
there's gonna be a lot of bugs just
watch off for lab but other than that
just building out an entire platform
where you have like a user system a
payment system the actual functionality
of the app like the landing pages the
fret and the back and there's a lot of
things that can go wrong and a lot of
things to build out so it's gonna take a
lot of time and effort to build out the
actual app on the business side of
things again the typical stuff that
comes with a business if you're gonna go
like the paid marketing route where you
pay for advertisements to promote your
app do shots as they were intended by
plastic directly in your mouth
that's gonna take a lot of money if
you're gonna go with the organic route
[Applause]
it's gonna take a lot of time and a lot
of effort to build out block-post
videos whatever else you're gonna use to
like grow organically the number six
thing that I wish I would have known is
called technician versus entrepreneur
again if you're a developer going in
this to build a SAS app why are you
doing this because you want to code or
are you doing this to solve an actual
problem in the marketplace and build a
business and if you're going at this
because again you want to code it's fun
you're passionate about it and you want
to make money you're probably better off
just getting a high-paying tech job
because then you're being paid just a
code and not focus on the business side
of things and to take on both the tech
side and the business side is a lot of
work I remember reading for ela must
have been PayPal because he was working
on both the business side and the tech
side of things with the coding he had to
work like 23 hour days at times so if
you don't want to do that that your
might be better off just getting a job
or again partnering up with
to take care of the business side while
you just code so now we've gone over the
six things that I wish I would have
known
here are my general recommendations it's
that I would recommend if this is your
first business that your that you've
ever started I would probably recommend
going after a service business or
getting a high-paying tech job first
here is what either route that you take
whether that be a service business where
maybe you're building websites for other
businesses or maybe you get a
high-paying touch up at a SAS company
both will give you the insights that you
need from the industry by actually being
in the industry first before building
out an entire SAS app and it will give
you a bunch of skills that you can use
when you actually go out to build a SAS
app and it will give you a ton of money
to fund a SAS up in the future and it
will give you some valuable connections
that you can use in the future as well
and if you want to go the high paying
job prowl I will link below my free
cheat sheet a very easy and simple
tactics tricks whatever you want to call
it that I put into my resume to help me
get like calls and job offers plug in
and it helps me land my dream job of a
$40 per hour
work from home web development job now
we'll be linked below for free I
guarantee you you would not find these
tactics anywhere else because I combined
marketing copywriting into resumes you
would not find that anywhere else a link
below for free the next thing I would
recommend is that you build an audience
first or you start building an audience
while you're building out the SAS
business this will make everything so
much easier because the number one
problem that every entrepreneur faces
when they first start out is that no one
knows look and that is important because
people buy from people they know like
and trust and if users don't know you
then of course they're not gonna like
you because they don't know you and then
on top of that they're not gonna trust
you either so they're not gonna buy from
you take my youtube channel for example
and the resume thing that I shamelessly
plug earlier in the video
full disclosure there's an upsell in
there where I upsell people into
something that cost money and the only
reason I made a good amount sales from
that resume product even though my
channel is like super tiny right now in
the grand scheme of things is that
people what they know and they like and
they trust me how do I know that they
know like and trust me because they only
buy stuff from people that they know
like and trust someone else out there
might have a
any product that's better than mine but
because people know like and trust me
they're gonna buy mine compared to this
stranger that they don't know building
an audience takes time so if you wants
to do that I would start right away but
if you really want to build a SAS up
without doing these things again take
what I say with a grain of salt that
it's not like people have done this
before without doing this stuff like I
mentioned it's just my recommendation
and if you watch the end of this video
and you still want to build a SAS app
you have a validated idea that people
would actually want to buy you're in the
right position you have the capital then
here are the number one resources that I
recommend if you're gonna be coding this
yourself the number one course that I
recommend is the build a SAS app with
flat scores by the sky named Nick this
course is very cheap compared to like a
lot of other online courses out there I
think it's like 50 or 60 bucks and this
course it's like well the best courses I
have ever bought this guy Nick walks you
through how to build a fully functional
like production-ready SAS app and gives
you all the code to do it and wash
through every single little step so you
can have like a fully functioning SAS
app that includes like the user system
the payment system recurring payments
integrating with stripe the actual like
the actual app the functionality on the
app he goes over all of that in this
course and it is just super super worth
the money one of my favorite parts is
that I asked like a lot of questions
during my time using this course and he
got back to me within like 24 hours or
less sometimes he got back to me in like
an hour which is like absolutely unheard
of with online courses and it just shows
like he actually cares about his
students which is pretty cool that will
be linked down below and yes of course
it's an affiliate link because I really
like this course again the number one
book that I recommend is the lean
startup if you hear these terms like
pivot or like validating the idea or MVP
I'm pretty sure it originated from this
book it's really popular and I would say
like if you're gonna build a SAS app
this book is required the author
actually walks you through how he built
a SAS app so it's like the perfect book
for the scenario the number one book I
would recommend for developers going at
this is the e-myth
because it goes over like the common
pitfalls that leads to small businesses
failing because these like technicians
like one developers go into this
business making that just because they
know how to code they're gonna be
successful which is pretty much like
dead wrong the community I told you guys
about of other people like doing SAS
apps
it's called any hackers and it's a forum
but it's not like a like a ghetto a
traditional form it's a really nice well
developed form but but I believe it's
made by stripe the payment processor and
it's by far one of the most active and
healthy communities I've come across
online so I super recommend it like
people share their business staff like
how much revenue they're bringing in
from their SAS app or other online
businesses and it's really cool so if
you stuck around to the very end let me
know what route you're gonna take with a
SAS app after watching this video number
one because I really care and I read
every single comment and number two for
that YouTube algorithm I just say it
subscribe to this channel but I already
said it like five times so follow me on
Instagram Jake trend I oh if you want to
like stock me online over their
recommended videos if you're interested
and working from home from a remote job
you can learn about like my absolute
favorite things about working remote in
this video right up here and if you want
to learn how I got my $40 per hour work
from home well development job like step
by step I reveal all the secrets watch
this video right here thank you so much
for watching I will see you guys in the
next one